i loved your work on season two of the
mandalorian
um you know but i've loved your work on
so many different things
uh but universally season two of the
mandalorian
uh i don't know anyone who's like oh
that wasn't good you know like everyone
seems to
like to love the season so my thing is
that uh i know they're filming uh boba
fett now and then they're gonna film
mandalorian season three
uh can you say if you're involved in
either of those
oh i can neither confirm nor deny my
involvement in the
the you know the ongoing universe that
they have so wonderfully created
but i can say that thank you for i'm
glad you appreciate the second season it
was so much fun to work on because just
what john favreau and dave filoni have
done there with the star wars universe i
think they have
one opened up a whole new world of the
star wars universe where
those who were excited before can you
know have a new avenue of exploration
and those it's you know
a whole new set of star wars fans are
being born
or or being developed with these new
characters and that's a super exciting
thing to
to be attacking this universe on two
fronts both old and new
is a really cool thing that they've done
how did you first get involved
in doing second unit for mandalorian was
it a project that you were sort of
looking to do or
you know how did it happen no that that
came to me actually
um i was editing extraction and a friend
of mine colin wilson who's the line
producer on the show an executive
producer
on mandalorian he called and you know
was just wondering what i was doing he
was
some you know super secret star
wars-esque thing and i was like it
sounds interesting he's like would you
be involved in meeting with
with john and and dave and i was like
i'd love to sounds really cool because
i'm you know i'm editing here so i'm
very busy
but if there's times when i can get away
to help you guys i'd love to so i met
with a minute you know it was we hit it
off right away john is a very um
he's very smart guy and very kind of i
would describe his family oriented
he likes to to work with people that he
you know likes and has worked with
before
so to be invited into that space is an
honor and i will be you know forever
grateful to have the opportunity because
i
feel like every day on set i was
learning something
you know if not from john directly from
other people from every department they
just surround themselves with great
filmmakers
and it was an honor to be a part of the
technology that they're using in the
volume
is jaw dropping i watched that
featurette on
yesterday the hour long featurette on
making season two
and it's it's incredible what you can
now do
um and the thing that i think is so
striking
is that you're on a soundstage but
you feel like you're outside because of
the lighting
you know look there's no it really it's
it's just amazing can you sort of talk
about your experience working with the
volume technology
and what really struck you about it yeah
it's an incredible technology they
they've really tapped into something
that is
i think gonna revolutionize the way
people are approaching
at least certain aspects of filmmaking
in one way
it was very interesting and kind of uh
to see
a throwback in a way that people were
rather than just shooting in front of
blue screen and saying oh well you know
we'll fix it later
there is a virtual scouts that you were
doing and designing
the locations and the shots and
storyboarding them very specifically
almost when you were shooting on film
and you had storyboards and it was
that was the process it's almost a step
back to that in a good way
where people you know actors have a real
environment that they can work in
you you've planned kind of every shot
and every way that you want to do it
there's some
room for adaptation and improvisation
but it's very
very much laid out in an orderly fashion
and just kind of
very well planned so that that was
really cool aspect but then
the it kind of for interior
stuff or for for the you know the time
that
all dps love like magic hour you know
when the sun is just setting or just
rising
it's fantastic for that now midday type
stuff like um
it's really hard to replicate the power
of the sun it's just a certain feeling
in the light that you just
really can't so often times for those
daylight stuff we would actually go out
and shoot exteriors in front of blue
but then the the flexibility it gives
you and the
to shoot in a very creative way because
you can with the
not it's not that easy as a push of a
button but you can adjust the lighting
very specifically to get a look and a
you know a feeling that you want so that
it really opens up creative avenues for
dps and directors
which sequence was for you like the back
breaking one
the one that maybe like really took a
long time
a lot of work went into each one of
these sequences but truthfully
it never feels like work to me when
you're working with
you know such great people and i was but
i would say that
the most moving parts and planning that
went into the execution and i think
satisfaction with the final product was
i believe it was 207
the um the tr i called the train
sequence but the sequence when they're
on top of the
the the vehicle and so it's because you
know that stuff was
they had we had practical vehicle on you
know
different mechanical rigs we were
shooting
outdoors and he had a certain amount of
light and you know people are the stunt
performers and actors are in prosthetic
makeup
and you know there's only a certain
amount of time to shoot it and there's
very specific
uh shots that that we were trying to get
and so
there was a lot of moving parts into
that but then for that to come out as
as fun as it did and as kind of you know
sharp and clean and with the craziest
thing and gonna mention this is the
um you know the the visual effect it
would look like
there were plates but all of the
environment i was told by
richard the um you know the head of the
vision effects department
was created in cg other than what we
were
on other than like the things that were
immediately touching as an entirely cg
environment
that um so the level of
craftsmanship and and artistic
uh capabilities of the computer
generated images now is
unbelievable like i was fully immersed
in that sequence and i thought they did
an amazing job cool to be a part of
i think what people are not realizing is
you look at that sequence
which is so well done and then you think
what that is gonna look like in like
three years
or five years as this technology gets
better and better
and they figure out like cheats on it
you know um
like i can't believe like when you get
to like if they ever get to like
mandalorian season five
they're gonna look back on season two
and be like should we redo it you know
like
it's so much better that yeah the
the expansion and growth rate of the
capabilities of these
you know game engines or the computers
and
is exponential like the speed with which
it's changing it's really hard to keep
up with and i think that's
one thing that john and the you know
that everyone over there mandalore and
is doing so well is staying on the
cutting edge
on the forefront of technology so that i
think you will if you if you get to a
season five
you know if the world is so fortunate
you they will be right there at the
cutting edge and it will be
you know they won't be satisfied with oh
well it worked really great in season
one no they they want it to be the best
cutting edge leading the pack
as far as the technology goes one of the
things i learned
because i spoke to robert rodriguez
about directing his episode
and he told me that like man i can't
remember exactly what he said
but he said like the script was like 13
pages or 18 pages it was very short
and he's like he was talking to john and
basically saying
um you know i cut fast this episode
might be 10 minutes
you know and he's like well that's why
you're here is to add to it so one of
the things that i learned
about mandalorian is all the scripts
were short none of them were that long
and it was up to the directors to sort
of flesh out things
so could you sort of talk about what it
was like working with the various
directors
to sort of turn these episodes into
30-minute things
when maybe on the page it's not that
long
yeah it's true like you'd get the script
and you'd read it you know in 20 minutes
and be like how we're going to make this
into a you know half hour or
almost an hour you know depending on the
um who's directing
but the the fun of it was
especially getting to work closely with
robert rodriguez who's a hero of mine a
filmmaking
legend and i grew up reading his books
and watching his movies and
um so to work with him was a dream come
true i was a little fanboy i was just
like oh my gosh i'm working with robert
rodriguez
uh so that was a dream come true but to
watch him
craft the story around
basically kind of you know ideas for
action set pieces
the script was you know got everyone
from a to b but he's like well wouldn't
this be cool
and the again the collaborative nature
of that
environment that john's created is they
you know john will be like yeah run with
it or and
robert might be like hey sam you know
what do you think here and i would give
a thing and we'd run with it so it
became this synergistic
group of filmmakers and you know also
again very
um blessed that he would let me run off
with a camera and shoot because you know
he's
he shoots fat robert shoots fast he
shoots great stuff
and he's got a really good feel for
action so for him to trust me
to shoot action that would kind of
represents him as the director because
his name's on the episode i get you know
i'm back there at the back you know
second director but in his episode to
let me
have some of the freedom he did was an
honor and you know i i hope it
that he's happy with how it came out
because it seems like you know a lot of
people were i am pretty proud of what we
put together well the thing that uh that
i also learned in that featurette is
that
the the show has two units going at all
times
it's not like you can get that thing
done with just first unit
you know like there's a lot to do so
what were you
like can you sort of talk about the fact
that there are two units going all the
time
and for people that maybe don't
understand what that means what does
that mean
yeah for those who don't understand a
second unit is generally a part of the
filmmaking process that is designated to
shooting action
visual effects plates or you know pickup
shots that they weren't able to get on
the main unit the main unit stays with
the
the main story the main cast and kind of
travels through their schedule
and then there's either where you have a
lot of stunt performers and you don't
need a lot of the cast the second unit
comes in and can
knock off a lot of important work for
the movie or
feature or sorry or you know series or
you you know run off to sometimes hawaii
to get plate shots or you know run down
to the
um wherever and get things that they
need to tie all the pieces together so
on something this big and so many moving
parts and
such a short time span because they what
i think they've done amazingly is
the kind of feature film level um
tv and there's such a short turnover in
television
you know you only get a certain amount
of time to shoot these episodes maybe
seven to ten days
and so to to get the level of excellence
that they're looking for it's helpful to
have two units going at the same time
because
you know you're getting twice the work
so i wasn't i was heavily involved with
the second season
and you know doing basically whatever
they needed me to do i was i would work
with
different directors at different times
on different parts of
you know different episodes and whatever
i could do to help that's
that's just kind of my approach to
filmmaking and and
you know work in life really is like how
how can i help how can i be of service
what is it that we need to do to get
this done and you know make it the best
possible for everybody involved uh when
you're working on something like
mandalorian uh you mentioned like for
example robert trusts you to do some
action
was that the way it was with all the
different directors like i mean you have
a really good track record
and people know your work so is it sort
of like you know the director's talking
to you and saying
you know we need to accomplish this go
do it like can you sort of talk
about how much freedom you had i was
granted a lot of freedom on that show
because
uh it does help having a a track record
now at the time
you know to be fair the extraction
hadn't come out so they didn't know like
as a director they didn't really
know they knew i was working on a movie
like editing it together but i have um
you know extensive background and that
people have seen my action
directing before in movies like the
avengers or captain america
you know some of the different things
are atomic blonde so they know i can
handle action but the thing
that you know because great if they
sometimes would hand you an actor
like hey can you pick up this scene and
you can get to shoot a scene
you know again because it's just trying
to help them take care
of things that they may not have the
time to do and it's great to be trusted
to do that and it was it's always great
when when you feel
included in the because sometimes like
they came in late for the second
season the first season they had their
little family and to to come into that
you know in the second season sometimes
different projects could be a little bit
standoffish and they'd be like hey you
know
we got a way we do things we don't want
you to be involved but
i have to credit john it starts at the
top so john and all the
you know department heads were very
accepting of the the new guy which was
me
and some of my ideas and ways of wanting
to do stuff so i felt
very thankful that they were so open and
willing to work with me
typically speaking say you're getting
ready to do
one of the episodes how much time did
you actually have for each episode
before you started filming
to sort of break down what you wanted to
do and the behind the scenes
and how much is it just like man we are
really cutting it close on these
things they were very big
on preparation so we did have time to
practice the things we needed to
practice if it was a big intricate
action sequence or
design set pieces that were going to be
involved in the action so that
they were very big on prep and and i
think they're correct
in that the more prepared you are the
the easier it's going to be to get those
you know days accomplished in the short
amount of time you do
and finish an episode in 10 days when
you're trying to shoot future quality
stuff
so i i never really felt rushed uh which
was great and surprising on tv show now
when you get there on the day
yes on a feature film like working on
the avengers i might have
four days to shoot an action sequence
where in this one you have one
so you are you are still up against it
but that prep time which they gave us
which was fantastic
allowed you to uh come up with stuff and
execute you know you have to
also manage your expectations like
there's there's certain levels of scale
that you're not going to be able to
achieve because it's not
you know feasible in that time but i
think for for the time we had and for
what we pulled off in that season some
of the big epic sec pieces i was
i was pretty impressed with how well the
team coalesced and brought all those
elements together in a timely fashion
one of the things about um the
mandalorian that maybe is an advantage
is that a lot of people are wearing
helmets and it's not your
uh you know your your brad pitt if you
will having to
perform something you know it could be a
stunt person or a lot of stunt people
under helmets
there's a lot of uh advantages to your
a lot of your main characters being
helmeted and fully covered basically
it gives you the ability to you can be
shooting on
two units and still achieving the same
thing with the same character if you
need to
now we tried to bounce around the the
same stun just because of
they've developed a way of moving in a
way of
you know a physical language of the
mandalorian and certain characters so we
tried to stay true to that
and keep those characters or the people
who doubled them
on screen and not you know mix it up too
much
but it does allow you to get a lot more
um i say a lot more bang for your buck
meaning
you could do longer takes of fight
scenes because it's the stunt performer
and not the actor you could do
you know you could get like i said more
um
setups because you can you know and not
to be
um discriminating but you can push the
stump people a little harder sometimes
you can say hey we've got to do that one
again because it wasn't great and
they'll you know they understand they're
more of the
you know in general the kind of
working class to where they go like they
will push especially if i'm right there
with them if i'm right there hey
and they look at me and they know i've
done it before they're like okay okay
i'll do it again and you can get that
extra
take you can go a little bit you know a
little bit uh longer a little bit
further
and which is super helpful in a tv
schedule because
you know you don't have a lot of time
and you got to move fast and you got to
be accurate so it's really helpful to
have
helmets on a lot of these players so you
could be move with the speed and
efficiency that you needed
to to make your days on a tv schedule
when mando
looks a certain way he like moves his
whole body
like there's a you know like there's
certain movements for each of these
kind of helmeted characters were there a
lot of takes you had to redo because all
of a sudden you realized oh wait you
moved your neck
like we have to make it so it's you know
uh
rarely because we tried and the people
that were performing in the suit at
different times were very
i mean they're great that's why they're
hired they're the best of what they do
so they know
they have especially by season two they
have adopted the movements
of the mandalorian and so you know
whichever one whichever
performer we got at that time you really
didn't have to worry too much about it
now
we were very cognizant we didn't just
say oh do how you want we were cognizant
and occasionally we'd have to go again
and say it
you know in your excitement that wasn't
quite the mando movement
you know like we need to try that again
but it was rare because we had such
great performers
were you on set when uh george came to
visit
uh i was there but i mean i was working
on another stage but i did pass through
and i saw i saw him there
i did he was you know is one of the he
was actually
you would have thought that the real
yoda had showed up i mean he kind of did
but every there was more people there
that day than any other day
on any other you know uh episode of the
whole season that was
it was as if you were at comic on the
stage where he was it was crazy
yeah i would imagine listen i mean he's
the creator he's the
the genius behind everything is it one
of those things that even though you're
working on this like
how hard is it to not want to go up to
george lucas and say
you know your work means a lot to me i
would really like to take a picture
or do you sort of just like you can't do
that because
you know oh i
i wanted to every you want to but then
there's like
you that the fanboy who just wants to
stop everything you're doing and go oh
my gosh
i'm going to wait in line if it takes an
hour and get a picture but
you know there's there's a couple
elements to it one is you know i've got
a job to do that you know they're
they're not they're not paying me to do
that that you know
to have to socialize the other is you
know he's he probably he didn't i mean
necessarily come down here to
take a bunch of pictures with people he
just wants to come and see the
you know the fruit of his labors of 30
40 years ago and he just went you know
so i'm like
let him enjoy it like that that's a huge
as huge as it is for
us to see you know him there
it's got to be an amazing moment for him
to see that this this idea that he had
back in the 70s was still
like is surging in popularity and going
strong and it's like this is something
that this is his baby
and now it's grown into a whole extended
family that he should be
totally proud of so i wanted to let him
soak that up i thought rosario dawson
did such a great job
and her look on the series is so awesome
can you sort of talk a little bit about
what it was like for you seeing her for
the first time
in costume with the makeup and maybe
also working with her at all
uh on crafting you know what uh with the
lightsabers and with her action
rosario's an amazing performer even you
know when she's not done up as uh you
know that the
her star wars get up do my research for
the second season i had watched clone
wars the animated series
that dave filoni you know had written
and directed a lot of those episodes
so to see
dave craft like she wrote that episode
dave veloni wrote and directed the
episode that she was in so you know that
that character was very near and dear to
his heart so to see his
effort and detailed um
i said dedicated um
time spent working with with rosario
working with everyone to make
every frame a masterpiece was really fun
he he had
that was his baby and to watch him you
know he was stressed he was like you
know pulling his hair out but he
he really in my opinion that episode was
one of the most
distinct because of the style was it was
so he was so committed to
that style you know just his choice but
that
kind of samurai movie style from opening
frame to closing frame
and he stuck to it and did such a unique
um look and feel that i i'd say that was
one of my
artistically one of my favorite episodes
so i hats off to dave
and rosario for bringing that character
to life well there's also just
that episode has such incredible shots
because um and i i'd like you to also
talk about the fact that these
lightsabers
have like they're they're on set
practically so you have the light
on the lightsaber and the dp is able to
use that light
to craft shots where it's like you're
not doing cgi later
you know like when the beam when the
lightsaber lights up across her face
it just looks so awesome yeah because it
is lighting up across her face
those the the props department made some
amazing lightsabers and that
it helps everybody because then there's
a
you know it's the difference between
having a rubber gun
on set and then having like a blank
firing gun
there's a certain level of you know i
mean i don't know it just changes the
way
you move and you're the level of power
you feel right when you have a light
an actual thing in your hand that when
you push a button it lights up
and then you can actually you know make
contact with like so the fights
you know they were making contact with
those things and you know we would we'd
break a few because that's what stunt
performers do
but we you know you could actually feel
the connection you could see the light
reflecting in their eyes it really
made it seem as if you were in the scene
and it helped the actors draw energy it
helped the crew get excited
it was super a super cool thing i was
really impressed with the lightsabers
yeah how involved were you in crafting
what she did
in that episode in the forest with all
the because
it it's just so well done yeah well
truthfully
like you look at the the boards that
most of that stuff
um you know ryan and the stunt team did
a lot of the choreography for the stuff
in the courtyard and they
execute stuff but a lot of those things
like they're running through the forest
and
the you know the reveals of cutting guys
down that was it
dave like he showed storyboards and
previews of stuff that he had been
working on for months
and dave filoni came up with a lot of
those beats just
you know up here he he knows his star
wars lord man that guy that guy's
he's an og oh i mean yeah there's
there's a reason why
um george came to set and his name is
dave
exactly you know pure and simple what do
you think
for fans of the series what do you think
i mean there's a lot of
information known about the volume and
everything else but is there anything
that you making season two that you took
away like
wow i wish fans knew about this
i'll just say some of the things that
were most enjoyable for me that i
appreciated i think fans would do is the
the use of practical effects
practical makeup practical you know um
creatures
rather than leaning because that you
know what's cool about it is the volume
is so
amazing amazingly cg and that's like a
great use of that technology
so then to offset that and to make you
feel like it's connection
they use you know like like little baby
yoda little girl goo
that's that's a real you know
animatronic puppet the thing could like
and it can freak you out and you just
find yourself
like smile because you know the guys and
they'll mess with people like the guys
the puppeteers
like if you sit in there like they'll
look up at you and like you know
do the droopy eyes and his ears will
drop down and you're like oh my gosh
it's alive
and so you connect with it on a level
that you could never do with a cg
character or if you're holding like a
you know
a tennis ball and they're gonna put it
in later so that and then what you
mentioned like the lightsabers like
having so many things be practical was
both a kind of a throwback for me of you
know the
when older movies were made and
everything it wasn't relying so much on
cg
but also you know you're in a universe
that is so reliant on cg and this
environment they were in that
juxtaposition was really fun for me as a
fan
of the franchise and of filmmaking
technology
i'm almost done i promise but i of
course have to talk about boba fett
um can you know watching robert and
talking to robert about
being able to um bring boba fett back
uh into mandalorian and having him just
kick
ass uh talk a little bit about um how
involved
were you with the boba fett stuff and
just maybe what it meant to you as a fan
as a fan there's not a whole lot better
than that moment when
when mando looks up and sees you know
beau's ship come in
and go down like you know you're like oh
[ __ ]
and then one of the again one of the
cool moments and i think robert might be
the best director to
give that moment to is when when he
shows up
you know we did a lot of cool stuff with
him with his club and like in the ropes
but when he shows up
in the armor like that that's
the way he you know captured that and
that you know that was all in his head
we helped with moves and things but the
the feeling of that of the the low
angles and the slow motion that was all
from robert and i think
that as a fan just you know you were
there smiling every day on set man this
is going to be so awesome
yeah it was kind of good i'm gonna go
out there
it was okay yeah were you there at all
for
the very very end when you're back in
jabba's palace
uh i was not there that day i was
shooting other stuff yeah i was not
there that day
when did you hear that that was going to
be included
when did you first hear that that was
going to be included and that they were
making
a boba fett series well i didn't even
like i had no i had no idea like like i
said i was on
even with this i'd get the scripts and i
would read that but then
it was when i wasn't there my focus went
on i think while they were doing that i
was working on episode seven like the
train sequence
so it kind of just went over my head and
i didn't really pay much attention
to it and when it was mentioned that
like he might get his own spin off i was
like oh man that's amazing like and
who doesn't want to see like mando's
been so great for
for fans of the star wars universe to
add this other
epically awesome character to the canon
that's going to be fantastic
well the thing that i couldn't believe
was because i know how much
boba meant to robert and now robert's an
executive producer on that show i don't
know how many
episodes he's going to help him i don't
know exactly the details
but it says a lot that robert wants to
be involved
in that series it just tells you how
much you
really love that character he loves the
character
loves the star wars universe like he
would show up to sit with a leather
jacket and like pop it open and he'd
have like on the inside the lining was
all star wars characters and boba fett
and
man it's like he's a total fan and so
when he that opportunity i think he was
extremely excited you know not to speak
for robert but he seemed like a kid in a
candy store when he was on set
when we were doing episode 206 he was he
was beyond happy
um what did you possibly borrow from set
or were there any cool crew gifts that
you guys got
crew gifts i think i got i got a
sweatshirt it's pretty cool
i got like a uh gotta i don't know where
it's around here somewhere but i got a
nice hoodie that was um
you know very thoughtful gift so i was
hey any kind of i mean i've been doing
it so you know
for 16 years now any kind of that stuff
i've got so much
of that stuff sitting around that it's
like oh man not another one but
this is one like having something from a
star wars
you know working on a star wars project
that's one that you're going to hold on
to forever because that's a little bit
of history and so that was
special